it's that time again time for you
PlayStation Plus members to get a look
at what free games you can grab next
month I'm Tony and this is your May
games line up ps4 owners can grab the
gorgeous underwater exploration game
Abzu which made game spots list of the
best games of 2016 that's coming to
North America only Europeans will get
the twin-stick shooter RPG hybrid
alienation both territories can also hop
into tales from the borderlands ps3
players can hack and slash through blood
knights and run their own pirate town
with portrayal 3 pirates and merchants
and on the Vita side you'll get the
shooter laser disco defenders and the
puzzle game typewriter thanks to cross
by both of those can also be played on
ps4 the new PS plus games will be
available Tuesday May 2nd until then you
can still grab April's games including
drawn to death and lovers in a dangerous
space-time hit that subscribe button if
you want to be the first to know about
each month's new games and for you Xbox
fans out there you can always check out
our games with gold lineup too
[Music]
you